all right di Dante
Dante where'd you grow up where are you
from originally oh from Compton
California you know bullets and
Rosecrans areas no probably pretty much
known as Lotus Park
back in the days Lewis Park mob
what was your family like
amazing
in a sense uh back then my family was
was pretty much together you know they
were
pretty well kept together Christian
family well my moms came from
Mississippi my uncles came from
Mississippi or Chicago either way it was
in between and um
the dirt roads have killed Michael
Mississippi to be exact
and they came to California for a new
life like everybody else you know the
south is the south is pretty rough you
know they wanted to come and get
into a new world
so to say
um
moms is I believe she's the youngest out
of the sisters like I got my uncles
and
it was a real how do you say traditional
black family from the south you know you
had everybody went to church on the
weekends
um cousins were in the military
I idolize my cousin Cornell growing up
because he was he was that dude he was
that image he was he was who I wanted to
be like
um
or either that on my stepdad or my
stepdad he came from background of
military he did contract work he built
probably about he part took probably
about building like three of the
Marriotts in Palm Springs tall dude
older about like 30 years older than my
mom I would later find out and um
so we stayed together
but um it was
it was different for me
I guess at a young age I was
I was more sort of a abstract to the
normality of the people around me
whereas a lot of other kids they went
and played football or they ran into
these type of things I tried it but it
wasn't really me I was more into artwork
and you know different type of dance and
and those type of things and uh
they got me in trouble my mouth got me
in trouble a lot so you know my my mom
was more so to speak whoop my ass a
whole lot and uh it worked at some point
in time but as a kid gets older he
becomes you know tolerant to certain
things so you just can't keep whooping a
child as they grow older you know and um
my mom was a tough cookie you know
in this day and age now I respect how
she treated me I respect the the things
that we went through because if I didn't
go through it
I'd either be dead in the street dead in
prison or or dead in one of those group
homes that they that they had me and
once they took me away
um
let's see it was
it was always a controversy with her and
my dad you know my dad who's dead now he
died in about 2001 took two bullets to
the head and three to the back in
Linwood California standing out front of
the same liquor store that he grew up in
and you know when my grandmother who was
sick with cancer who's passed away now
as well
she sent her sent him to go live with a
Hispanic family and he would work in a
liquor store and years later after my
grandmother had passed away it you know
it
a man's mother's dog you know this
little boy lost his Queen and he went
back to the streets he was outside and
you know he um
he was getting some formula for my
sister standing out front and a guy came
up to you know buy some dope or whatever
he's doing a little slanging
um and uh
they get into a physical altercation
and my dad won but this dude Hispanic
dude from the local you know cholo hood
or whatever he ran around the corner and
he came back and he caught my dad
slipping and that's when he murdered him
open case Cold Case whatever you want to
call it you know and that's it is what
it is there was no more investigations
that went into it or none of that and I
mean let's look at him God from Compton
California black God statistic we're
Expendable and I'm really looking to
that type of stuff
but as at a young age I I didn't know my
father really didn't know him I knew my
stepdad and
he ruled with 100 Fizz you know you
weren't even allowed to call him pops
you know you call me daddy you know you
go to work I mean you go to school you
get your schooling done if there was a
flaw on a progress report he'll have you
by the time he got home you know he is
go out there and get a switch you know
this planet is coming right now you're
doing your homework if there was a a
wrong mistake on her and you know you're
supposed to have this right and he had a
handful of gold come here put your head
there tap you right in the head and um I
learned from
from him what hard work is because even
after we were done with the homework he
would bring these buckets big asses
buckets of just wires wires that he was
getting from the places from the
Marriotts and stuff and it would be me
my mom my sister and my dad
like you're a razor here you fill up
this trash can you fill up this trash
can and I want it done by the end of the
night so it was just imprinted in me as
a kid like all right this is hard work
but
at the end of that you know
it was hurting my mother
the things that he was doing on the side
you know just infidelity cheating and
all that type of stuff you know it's old
school Southern dude you know as long as
I take care of the bills and the kids
are fed no matter what I do out here in
the streets
um and I'm like all right I'll come home
I'm like where is you at I was at dad
fixing the house over here is that his
friend house fixing some walls that's
what he told me to say uh he was over
his friend's house fixing some walls and
you know I mean the kid I'm in the room
with with you know this lady's kids
eating pizza we having a party over here
so it's cool long as I keep going around
meeting my friends you know it was it
was he was such a Savage with it that he
had sex
with his best friend's wife at their
kids birthday party while I was there
and I I walked in the room and um I had
went home one day and he forgot to tell
me when you're a kid he forgot to tell
me don't tell your mom he forgot to give
me the script so when my mom asked like
where'd she go oh I was at my my dad
took me over here to this lady house and
he was in there you know laying with her
and I was chilling outside and doing
yada yada yada
and she found out and it it devastated
her but she didn't leave
and I look like this this is weird like
she didn't leave and
um
she had jobs always been a nurse a
little five foot five foot one dark skin
Creole lady from Mississippi lifting
people up out of wheelchairs and taking
care of him as a nurse real quiet you
know my mom still to this day quiet she
keeps to herself
and um one day she just said she had
enough she she had enough
and um she put me my sister in the car
and we drove down to Long Beach
and uh we went to my auntie's house and
we we stayed there and she just said nah
but before that he
he tried to put sand in the gas tank so
you put sand in a woman's gas or
anybody's gas tank and they're trying to
drive from Palm Springs to Long Beach
there's going to be some issues with the
car
and that's why I seen the first blow
that my mother took you know the first
blow to her her confidence her
self-esteem her dignity as a black woman
you know or just a woman in general
because she she went to family members
and she was like you know I just need
this amount of money chump change chump
change
see I just need 300 so I can get my car
fixed so I can dry my kids around you
know get the kids or where they need to
go and
they shut the door on her you know your
family shut the door on you and I seen
how I messed her up until this day it
still affects her because she don't go
around like that you know she don't she
she she distanced herself and sometimes
distance is the best security
um
she just started doing things solo we
live with my Auntie Mary who's rest in
peace now
pillar of one of the great pillars in my
family
um she's resting
and we live there me my mom my sister in
a room all our clothes everything else
in storage the car is gone and she
started from the bottom working there
um eventually we will move out and get a
place right around the corner and I was
in um Junior High School
um
and around that time we had moved in
there I got the word that my stepfather
had died
driving from Palm Springs
and my cousin the one that I idolized
was paralyzed you know essentially from
from the neck down in that car accident
he was destined to go do college
military all that type of stuff and he
uh he was paralyzed in that accident and
my father died trying to Swerve out the
way of something
drinking and driving as you know as
usual he would keep a a
he would keep a igloo in the trunk and
he would have a fifth of black velvet
and he would have a two liter of Coke
and whenever his his cup would empty
he'd get out and he'll go back there on
the side of the road he'll pour his
drink get back in and I'll be like Dad
you know I'm on some of that soda he's
like no this grown folks soda like Dad I
want some of that soda and he'll be like
well here boy go ahead and have you a
sip you know and that's that's where the
drinking started from he's seven years
old pops gave me that first shot of
Canadian whiskey and from then on I'm
like all right and my cousins would give
it to me because now they're like oh
that's you know it's entertaining to
watch this kid just dance around and be
around us and look at him we're not
giving them a lot no we're gonna give
him just a little bit he's gonna get his
dance on he's gonna fall asleep just
like the grown folks so I wanted to be
around him and I felt like I was
impressing him so I continued to do it
moms will move around the corner and
she got her first
first boyfriend
she got her first boyfriend
and
um my sister will be allowed to go with
her father we have different dads you
know this guy you know low riders pulls
up on motorcycles you know he got a
house
kids whole family and all that and
that's when the division started in the
home because I began to Envy my sister
you know I can be my sister and po
thanks she she has a disability I'm
envying you when it's not your fault
it's the adults
and I'm like damn you get to go spend
time with your dad and I don't get to
spend time with my dad what did my dad
do you know what's what's so bad about
my dad where you get to always go over
here why do they favor you you know he
can't even bring clothes around it's
like no take your clothes you get out of
here you know and um
as time progressed I I just I had a
hatred in my heart for my sister because
of that
you know I I disliked her
um my dad came around one time and I
seen him he showed up at the door and my
mom shut the door right in his face
and then hatred for my mother began
there
you know like a real just
why are you taking this from me
everybody else gets to have their father
but you take this away from me you know
you you my step dad's gone you know what
the kids do it blame their mothers you
took this we could have stayed out there
you took my father away from me you took
the house you took the cars you took all
this type of stuff and and I began to
just live in and become real quiet and
resentful towards people and um
my mom got her first boyfriend
and I met the dude and I seen him bigger
fellas from Linwood and uh
he came into the house and I was sitting
there one day and I was all I would
always watch him like a hawk like a hawk
and I cut my eyes and my mom's he said
tell my mom that little boy keep cutting
his eyes maybe I'm gonna [__] him up one
day
still cut my eyes at him you know he
took me to his family house and I'm
third grade by this time I don't know
how to read anything I don't know any
math I don't know any reading the little
school that I did go to out there in
Palm Springs they just passed me through
you know just you're the real black kid
that we get so we already think that
you're stupid so just send them on
through me might be an athlete one day
and um
[Music]
and this this guy he would try to teach
me stuff but I I didn't respect it
because I didn't feel like
it was genuine so I would talk back and
I would put up a fight and then you're
not my dad and um and then the way he
would start to treat my mom you know he
abused her kindness he abused that
southern hospitality and she didn't
notice it you know and she she went down
the path of you know essentially taking
care of this dude
um
and then things came along my grandma
would come and live with us at the time
she had lost both of her legs and she
would live with my auntie before that
but diabetes and cataracts took a toll
and you know we
reign of C was the type of individual
you couldn't do anything wrong you
couldn't do a damn thing wrong she'd
just look at you say it's all right baby
just do better next time
even when she was blind she went blind
because the cataracts Grandma I want
something to eat Grandma being there
blind trying to make you a sweet potato
pie because you know that's what the
baby's like
and um she had lost her legs
and grandma would end up coming to live
with us for a little bit that she left
my auntie Mary's house with my uncle
Danny
and um I would see my mom carrying my
grandma upstairs like a whole flight of
stairs because we didn't live on the
bottom floor we couldn't afford it those
were the better Apartments so she had
carried my grandma up the stairs put her
in a wheelchair take her to the room
give her baths take her to the apartment
take her to a hospital visiting she
didn't even have a car so it was just a
hustle and bustle and I looked at this
dude he wasn't doing [__] you just
sitting on your ass just collecting
everything and
um I came home one day from being at my
auntie's house and my mom was in the
restroom
when I learned my first life lesson as a
young boy
where the world was turning him into a
man
and um he was drunk he was banging on
the walls he was banging on the door my
mom was trying to shower she was trying
to take a bath and uh working at Long
Beach Memorial
um he punched the door in went through
the air climbed through the air you know
smashed my mom up and she's like what
are you doing he had her in the kitchen
and he had he had a knife to her
and I'm in a room with my auntie and my
sister be sharing with my grandma my
sister was sharing a room and I'm like
no I need to go
I need to go help my mom I need to go
and that's my mama I need to go no
matter how much I feel about her you're
not going to touch her
how little I am just there's something
in my heart to say I need to go fight
for my mom
and um
my grandma stopped me she held my hand
as strong as she could and she said nah
that's that's a Grown Folk thing right
there you need to you know you need to
stay out of that
but I still tried and she said no you
stay out of that and um he stayed there
dude left my mom was there Mom you all
right she said go back in the room I go
back in the room and I'm like no I need
to do something this don't feel right
now I went to school the next day and I
had speech classes to help me learn how
to read and you know do basic math to
speed me up
and I told my speech teacher like you
know just this dude put his hands on my
mom
can't call my uncles you know they I
don't think they would have you know
done anything something in my mind said
don't don't call them you know the
trauma's already done y'all abandoned
her and she couldn't even get a damn car
and um said this dude did this to my mom
and they came and got him snatched them
up I guess he went to jail or whatever
um and when I had got home
I was like I'm gonna be the hero like I
saved my mom I'm gonna be the hero yada
yada yada I was I was pumped up like
yeah Mama I'm I'm that dude for you
and I got home and I got my ass whooped
and my mom told me don't do that don't
ever do that again you stay at a grown
folks business and you don't go to the
police police not for us they don't help
us that just created more problems
what did you do
you know y'all kids y'all do this and
y'all do that and I'm like
damn and at that point in my head
everything altered so
we never go to the police after that we
never go talk to these people at the
schools we don't we don't do that type
of stuff a man doesn't do that you know
this is the family and um
she would have just
things happen to my grandma ended up
going back to Mississippi
she passed away a short time after that
a point came in where my auntie my
auntie shadelle
she was able to talk to my mom and I was
able to finally just spend some time
with my dad and it was like damn this is
you know this is a twin this is this is
me I'm talking all the way I see my
sisters my I got Seven Sisters I go and
I see my I see my sister's mom they
immediately grabbed my hands they touch
me you got Nails just like Mario you
talk like Mario you walk like Mario you
you everything that did that your daddy
was
and um I had about four visits with my
dad four visits I'm at my grandma
I'm at my Uncle Cheyenne
I was able to spend time with my aunties
that came down from Chicago
and then after those those you know four
visits it was like he came and said hey
I'm him you know I'm gonna make this
presence known I'm your father this is
me
you know
um
and you know the murder happened
time progressed
my heart became black and
I went to school and I had friends and
that's where the racial thing happened I
went to school for fourth grade Jane
Adams Elementary School Long Beach
California
had a friend named Sergio coolest dude
in the world we straight Sergio had
older brothers I guess that's all the
brothers had an impact on his life to
wear as you know best friends best
friends hey let's go to the bathroom one
day and we we go to the bathroom and I'm
sitting in there and they're like yeah
you know
some more Hispanic dudes come in
like I don't know anything about gangs
like that you know I see long ESL hit up
on the wall I don't know that as long as
I'm talking about you know Eastern
National Soccer League or something like
what is this what is this stuff written
on the walls and you know the gang life
had already entered their family you
know the racial thing had already
entered their family and um
at that moment in the bathroom you know
the dudes turned the lights off on me my
best friend called told me you know [__]
my office and I got jumped my three
Hispanic dudes with the lights off in
the bathroom
and then after that I was like all right
it was war
y'all you put the Line in the Sand is
this it is what it is I don't have to
talk to y'all y'all don't have to talk
to me you say something disrespectful
I'm fighting from now on
I gotta go home and my mama finna see
this see me all scarred up and stuff and
she's like oh what you been getting in
trouble in school so now I can't get in
trouble in school but I am getting in
trouble in school I can't explain to you
that the [__] is going on in my life
you wouldn't understand
I don't think nobody can feel my pain we
think that as a kid I thought that
nobody understands they don't know what
death is they ain't seen this they ain't
going through that and um
School became just a place I didn't want
to be
I didn't feel like
I was learning anything or it's just the
fact that I couldn't learn it was too
much [__] going on in my life
left that
time progressed
um
me and my sister we started to bond more
because Mom was working a lot some of
this lady was working a lot and I had to
take up responsibilities because there
was no real father figure in the
household
and I would clean up for my sister you
know what I'm saying I would I'll go to
the schools and walk her home
wrong she had to go get pads you know I
got to go in there to the store to get
pads embarrassed so everybody in the
neighborhood laughing at me oh you're
getting tampons like I just want my
sister you know whatever you know I'm
cooking for ironing clothes we got to go
to the laundromat we doing that all the
the typical [__] you see in the hood
Mama putting stuff in your name and all
that you know that type of stuff came
um
but it would just be the sudden burst of
just anger
that I received from from people you
know
and
time passed down the line and nobody
really knew what the [__] was going on
in my life excuse my friends I'm trying
to get out of this this cursing thing
trying to expand my vernacular
um
nobody really understood what was going
on in our in our household you know it's
black community Hispanic Community you
know you don't you don't we don't seek
therapy we don't do we don't do psych
meds we don't go talk to people about
the [__] that we have going on so it was
it was real tight kept and um as I got
older my tolerance for ass whoopings
like I say became I don't care about
this Mom you could whoop on me
I'm already whooping in these streets
I'm fighting these dudes in the streets
I'm fighting these dudes at school so
this this I'm becoming tolerant to it so
I guess she felt that you know the need
to take it a step higher you know I'm
saying all right these this building
working so this slap ain't working so
all right now I gotta I gotta really put
this to you
and you know it would become these
situations like all right you know you
get in trouble I got to give this to you
to this day
am I upset about it nah
I don't think so because a lot of those
a lot of those things you know it it
would have saved my life
and it saved
me from doing [__] because my intensity
level was so high
and um one day it just
it wasn't even a one day it was just a
build up it was a build up of going to
Harbor View or star view which a lot of
people may may not know of
um they were doing these psychotropic
things whatever just analyzing me and
they told my mom put him on meds so she
fell for it I fell for it
11 10 years old I'm on Zoloft something
that's supposed to be prescribed to an
18 year old I'm on a Risperdal
anti-psychotics my mom got to give you
these meds I'm running around sitting on
my my bed at home drooling and my mom's
not figuring out well she's like what is
going on with my son and she's she's
heartbroken at the fact that she can't
get through to me his heart's blackened
he's hardened by the streets he's going
through these things in life you know
can't go outside my sister can't go
outside just because my mom's not home
so we're just sitting in the house you
know we just in this [__] cage
um I did something at school and I
forgot what I did
and my mom just had that moment she
snapped hold me up
told me up and um the next day I had to
be at school she said you know you you
know put this on go to school you know
what happened you fell off a bike
teachers been hip to this you know
they've been here to this so I go in and
on this particular day it's the hottest
damn day of the summertime Dante why are
you in class with a full-blown
turtleneck on in the middle of the
summer time just sweating
um
I'm like I don't know
they send me to the Dean's office and
the dean is like uh what's going on with
you yada yada yada I'm like I'm good I
fell off my bike he's like I'm gonna
call your mother and let him know that
this that and the other if you don't
tell me what happened and show me what's
under your shirt
uh I pulled my turtleneck down
pull the sleeves up because I don't want
them to call my mom you know you you
play the hand play the game on my mind
there you got it out of me and um
they seen the bruises and they they seen
the marks and stuff like that and they
were like oh no you know that's that's
that's that's we can't go for this and I
told him you know every kid gets
whoopings what do you mean that's what
y'all call the parents for when they
messing up you know all right he needs
to be disciplined that's what y'all
doing
um at that time that's that's when
that's when life took a toll for his
words they took me away from my mother
took me straight out of school Lindbergh
Middle School
um
I told him you know if you take me away
from my mom I'd rather die I kill myself
if you take me away from my mom's
dug a hole even deeper
next to you know they took me to some
place ambulance pulled up they strapped
me down to a garden they took me to
Cerritos College Hospital
um as soon as I got in the door it was
just
this is a mental Asylum this is this is
where they send the crazy people I'm not
I feel like I wasn't crazy like I just
once said that I want rather die if you
took me away from my mom
um ran a bunch of tests on me
put me on even more meds they put me in
groups and all this type of stuff and um
my mom came and they said you know we're
not we're not allowing your son to go
back home to you they took me away from
my mom the doctor said that you know
he's such at a high risk with his
depression and you know um cutting on
himself you know I carve help into my
arm he doesn't talk
he lashes out at people when they speak
to him and other kids talk to him even
when they put me in an isolation room
you know other kids they fight and
they're sticking them with that you know
they call it Booty Juice the
tranquilizer kids are fighting grown men
fighting and they're jumping on them and
they're sticking them in their asses
with this just trank and putting them in
a mood in the room and sedating them I'm
asking him hey can you take me to the
isolation room
when I have me in there and they'll see
me in there just swinging my feet on the
end of the bed
and they ask me why do you like to be in
there it's peaceful I feel safe nobody
can get to me
and doctors just they seen it and it was
it was weird to them
um
I would get taken out of that hospital
placed with my my uh my auntie my Auntie
Mary and my Uncle Dan they took me and
my sister and
um
but before that it was I was supposed to
go to my auntie house left that one out
I was supposed to go to my auntie like
this real quick supposed to go to my
auntie and on the seventh day
you know I have my hopes up you know kid
has a hoax up I'm I mean it's crazy
people place everybody's going home they
get visits on the weekend and on a final
day I was supposed to go to my auntie to
live with her until I went back to my
mother and they come and they say you
know Dante go down there to the collect
phone and you have a phone call and I
pick up the phone and um
now I understand what she meant but back
then it was one of the most painfullest
things that I have felt
because I was anticipating something I
was anticipating the greatness I was
anticipating the happiness and um
she got on the phone and she let me know
that you know I can't take you
know my auntie couldn't take me
I was like so where am I supposed to go
so you know you're gonna go with your
Auntie Mary
you know damn I was really looking
forward to this you know like I'm here
I'm stuck I gotta wait an extra three
days to get out of here
you know and being at my Auntie Mary she
tried her best she tried her best I was
just too lost I was too gone you know
these this was a this was a child that
was molding and forming into something
completely opposite of what they had
seen
and um
I went there I lived with her and it was
just it was it was too much I was I was
a badass kid her kids were grown you
know your son your son is my cousin he's
in a wheelchair he's going through what
he's going through I couldn't even talk
to him I never asked him to this day
like
was it the pain that you were going
through of going through the accident
that had you feeling the way that you
felt towards the world
or
did you purposely have something ill
intention towards me because of what my
stepfather had did and we've never
talked about that to this day and I was
like I gave him his distance because
it's like I don't I don't know what what
happened or what it is and I lived in
that and I continued and I got in
trouble one day at school my auntie said
you know it's Deontay you got to go I'm
tired of coming down here to this school
I'm tired of you doing this I'm tired of
you doing that and um
they call my social worker Gemma Jima
I said I'm gonna pick you up and take
you to an emergency foster home and I
said I want to go to a foster home you
told me I wouldn't go to a foster home
and she was like well you got to go if
not you can go to jail you want to go to
LP I say you damn right take me to jail
I'm 12. take me to jail I don't want to
go live with these people I don't know I
don't see any all these movies Antoine
Fishers and all this [__] I don't want
to go with these people that's it's not
the right fit for me this is outside my
family
and she was like well all right well I'm
gonna get there just stay there for one
day just stay there for one day Dante I
said all right you'll come back tomorrow
and uh went there for one day
she didn't come back the next day she
didn't come back the next day and she
didn't come back for about two weeks
and I dropped off to these people's home
and
everything seemed all damn fine and
dandy
and
the next chapter happened where you know
you realize that you're just a chick
I'm somebody's check
you know I you wouldn't pay my auntie to
take care of me but you would pay these
people to take care of me you pay them
damn good and what I learned about being
in Department of Children family
services that the more
problems that a child has the more they
get paid
so if I can get a kid to get on meds I
can show that he has aggression problems
I have to keep taking on a therapy the
family doesn't want them the mother may
not want them etc etc he has so much
trauma they'll take that [__] and run it
to these people hey he needs this this
this this so before I was at the age of
what 14 I was somebody's four thousand
dollar five four thousand dollar check a
month
and I was only supposed to get 50 of
that a month and I didn't see that and I
live with these people and I they would
just feed me these hand-me-downs of kids
that have been gone seven years I'm
wearing clothes that are down to my
knees going to Junior High not giving
you know just all the things that you
would think that a kid's supposed to
have one into foster care it wasn't
happening it's not happening what
they're selling on TV it's not that
picket fence and the family thing that
they that they propagate to the world
about what foster care is you know is
that [__] doesn't happen and um
the the son that was there
we were getting to these beefs even with
the family I would have beats with them
and they would do [__] like this they
would have the family time in the living
room where you know they go in there and
watch movies the whole family whole
entire family
and I would try to come out and sit with
them and watch movies and they'll tell
me you know you can't be out here with
our family and I would say why you're a
foster kid you're not allowed to be out
here with us
and it was just that simple like just
the emotion of just having a living
thing so it's like you know have this
kid go back so I went in the room and I
would listen to on a crank up radio sit
there and crank the radio and listen to
music didn't have a TV in there he had a
game but that was his game you can't
touch it and um
one day it's another one day
um
I came back from seeing my sister we had
our our visits and stuff
and um the wife and husband had been
arguing a day before and I had my foster
sister
and she was the truth
she was the truth from the beginning I'm
talking about this this young lady was
like she stood up for everything like
You Know Tiffany haddish tells her
stories about being in foster care and
how she stands up and you know that
charismatic stuff that she does this was
this this young lady was dead and I
looked up to her and I seen the way she
stood her ground to these people the
father you know who are you
disrespectful little [__] and he was
just degrade this young chick the son
would go in there and get her in her
thongs and panties and [__] out of her
drawer he would cut her panties and
leave them on the bed call her nasty
[__] and stuff like that you know
um in the morning I would hear the way
to Dad who's a he was an ex-laker player
that's what he said the ex-laker player
lived in Bellflower and he would just be
going big on his wife the same way
enough his son was talking to this girl
he was mirroring the way that his dad
was talking to his mom
and the chick came in and she said you
know I'm out of here bro I'm like where
you going you gonna leave me I ain't
gonna have nobody she says I gotta go I
gotta go look at the way they treat us
I'm gonna pack my stuff don't let him
run over you baby boy don't let them run
over you and she's I'm about to go live
with some rich white woman that's gonna
give me my space
and like that she was gone
so I'm feeling here and I'm solo and uh
we're getting two with me and his son we
get into it because I'm like I'm about
to press my line now I'm doing what the
sister told me you know I'm doing with
their daughter letting me to do and I'm
like I'm doing this and uh
I snapped one day you know I snapped he
said something about my sister being a
[__] because she has a disability and
call my sister a [__] and he smacked
me over the back with a broom
and I was going to Bellflower high at
the time and uh I went to wood shop I'm
like nah I gotta get you back I'm
talking about my sister you know I'm
saying that's my weak spots you talk you
smoke bad about my sister
and I went to wood shop and I made it
back
and I formed this bat out of wood and I
put nails in the end of it like you know
like you see on Warriors the movie I was
like all right I'm about to do this I
got to teach him a lesson you know what
I'm saying I got to get my lick back I
got to make you stop talking about my
family like this that's my that's my
loved one that you spoke bad towards and
I left and the counselor called me in
like hey you know come in here and like
what's going on like what's going on
with your Foster family like you know
what's going on I don't like these
people I hate them they treat me like
[__] but I can't go anywhere
and um
she said uh what do you have in your bag
de Dante I have nothing
mind if I look in your bag or go ahead
so she looked in the bag and she pulled
out my club she's like what's this for
and I'm sitting there looking at her
she's like what's this for
like you know I'm I'm not going to tell
anybody
you know that the confidentiality [__]
went out the window I guess you know I'm
not going to tell anybody I said you
know my my foster brother hit me with a
with a broom
and uh you talk bad about my sister
so I'm gonna take this and I'm gonna hit
him with it
and she was just
analyzing you know psychoanalyzing me
during these moments where are you going
to hit him at oh I'm not going to hit
him in the head I'm gonna hit him in his
backer in his leg because I don't want
to kill him I just want to hit him back
for what he did you know I want him to
you know understand
and she said stay here she took my bag
and uh I was like can I go home now
he's like nah you're not gonna go home
I can hear sirens
like I said it's like tall [__] they're
coming to get me so I tried to get up
and run out she's like nah they locked
the doors on me they dragged me back in
the room they're like all right so
people want to talk to you now so they
shut down the whole [__] school turn
on the fire alarms
they parked the ambulance right in front
brought the Garney in they had sheriffs
on either side and they're sitting there
with their hands right there in the
holsters Mr farmer we just want you to
lay down on this garnie everything's
gonna be all right
they lay me down on the garnet they put
the strap me down strap my head down put
the things on me then go to Cerritos now
I end up at Torrance Hospital
stay there
for about 14 days now
and a foster lady comes to see me Miss
Angela
Miss Angela was a cool lady got my first
foster dog from this lady you know this
is where all the dog [__] I already
loved dogs but I got my first monster
dog and I moved in there and they had my
brother Fernando my foster brother my
brother Jacob and they had other brother
Michael in the back all these kids
trauma child abuse
my first Brothers
first foster brother he was he came from
El Salvador just a baby abandoned in the
street came to America and was adopted
my brother Jacob his father had on drugs
abused him put his head in the toilet
and stomped on it as a baby and then
Michael was just he was
he was so far gone that he couldn't even
talk you know he had a he had a thing on
his side whereas you know he had to
digest food through a tube for the rest
of his life but just the happiest kids
and at home and I was the oldest kid
that she brought in there for a while
you know Dante I usually don't bring
kids older kids I'm gonna try to keep
these boys safe and um
they had me there
the dad would you know he would take me
and teach me how to do Roofing went
fishing you know this was the American
dream I said damn fishing we're going
camping we're in a camper you know we're
sitting down at the table eating
home-cooked meals I was like oh this is
this is what's up you know and then
their identity became my identity which
caused identity crisis Within Me
because I believe this is where I was
supposed to be at
this this thing that you formed was so
beautiful and so perfect that I forgot
about home
and I started to say I don't even want
to go home anymore you want to go home
why would I go back to my mother you
know why would I go back to the person
that birthed me when I have all this
you know it's a house I lived in an
apartment I slept on a mattress in the
living room you know
why would I want to leave that when I
have this but
who I was becoming called up to me once
again at school
aggression just exerting aggression
you know
only way I can compare of of things to
make it simple is like when you get a
you get a dog and that dog has been a
stray and he's been running wild and he
doesn't have that that full fulfillment
at a young age of socialization where he
doesn't have the mother or he doesn't
have other dogs around they won't make
eye contact they don't know how to
socialize so they lash out
I in that stage of my life was that I
was lacking socialization so when kids
would shoot the birds they just talk
[__] oh
I didn't know how to respond
you know I was like all right do I shut
down I can't let you see me weak so I
will lash out and fight everybody fight
it didn't matter if he was a boy if he
was a girl you said something crazy we
gotta fight because I don't know how to
talk I haven't been taught how to you
know shoot the stuff
and um I got my dog
that was my only way of relieving stress
and watching Animal Planet at one point
I want to be a damn ASPCA cop
um
and they brought another kid in and
she's like I'm gonna give you a foster
brother
and he shared a room with me and I'm
like what's up bro and if something
about this dude that always rubbed me
the wrong way
um
then my damn dog died you know he had he
had ticks and he had worms and they they
went and got rid of the dog while I was
at school
you know and I was [__] up about that
I couldn't even see him you know he just
died I was like well can I get another
dog and I'm like well you got to do good
in school now now you're hanging the
school [__] over my head that's never
gonna happen and I had this Foster
brother and um he would always go home
and uh
yeah
a step-grandfather
and I seen the privilege
of what race would get you
he had a white grandfather he was half
white half black and his mother couldn't
see him but the grandfather could
and we would be in a room and he was say
stuff and everybody just watch out for
your brother you know make sure he's
cool I'm like all right and he went he
went and left with this dude one day and
he came back and when he came back he
came in the room and I noticed like hey
man did you pee on yourself
like don't get into bed if you peed like
you know just go in there and clean
yourself you know
and um it was in his on the back side
like a whole wet spot
like what the [__] is going on he left
and he came back again you know my
father went like you know get in there
and take a bath boy they don't be peeing
on yourself but it happens you know
traumatized kids do certain things
and it kept happening and the third time
he came in and I noticed it and I was
like nah it's something up
and I went in there and I thought
something was in my head I said I said
you know Mr Angela something going on
with him
and um she went and told the people at
the DCFS and they came and they stopped
the boy from having visits with this
dude they were doing investigation and
he came one day with a bat his banging
on the foster mom door these old people
oh like 60 70 years old they retired you
know the kids kids are grown and he
showed up banging on the door holder
white dude like you ain't giving my my
foster son and I mean my grandson he's
going to be able to come with me and
I asked him I was like man what happened
to you
sitting there wasn't like no bro what
happened like has he been touching you
has he been doing something to you he's
been doing something to your butt
and he melted and he said yeah
and they stopped letting him go over
there
at all
I was being just aggressive at school so
they took me out of the house and they
moved me to uh to Compton to Miss Gloria
Watson Butler to Kelly Parks remember
the name and all that um
I'm still going visits with him
uh my aggression at school got me kicked
out of a go and visit with him at home
I came over for a home pass with this
Foster family one day and they uh
they said you know your brother wants to
tell you something
and I go on there and I said what's up
Nando talk to me Fernando
he's like I don't want to talk I know
talk to me Fernando I'm your brother and
he always liked Xbox he played the damn
ATV Fury all day and we're playing Xbox
I said you know talk to me little bro
and he said you know
he would come in my room at night
what do you mean who the dog the
boogeyman what you know that that always
come in here checking on you he said no
he would come in my room at night and
get in my bed and he would lay with me
and he will hold me from the back
and uh he would touch me and talk to me
and this dude was at school and I was
like you know it's my brother right here
so it triggers
and it triggered we were outside and
they were barbecuing my foster mom and
foster parents out there I want to come
back home
and then triggers something in me you
know it triggered you know the weapons
you know you you've been tolerant enough
to this [__] so he came out there and I
was like you know what did you do this
to my brother for and they barbecuing
they doing the family thing and I'm like
no I'm gonna get it out of him I'm gonna
get it out of him
he wouldn't admit it and he wouldn't
admit and I'm sitting here like all
right
and I'm about what
12.
12 at the time or something like that no
I tied him to a post
and I just started hitting
with a belt
start hitting him
start telling no telling like what's up
bro
what's going on like what's what what
did you do
you know what did you do to this kid
you know what I'm saying
what did you do to him you just mirrored
the same [__] that this dude did to you
to this kid and you putting this baby
through pain I just I just kept hitting
him and I kept hitting him and I kept
hitting him and I kept hitting him in
the midst of you know they're creating a
family Barbecue and I kept hitting him
and I kept hitting him and he came and
stopped me and they said you know he
what are you doing
hello
at that point you know
they drove me back
I've never seen that lady ever again
they never allowed me to come over again
in fact they got rid of him they moved
him out then [__] around and uh moved
out of state
then I went through after foster home
foster home foster home
ended up in group homes in LA
still trying to recount the relationship
with my mother
at this point the streets had had me I'm
I'm living in L.A running down running
down Vernon with a machete
trying to fight dudes for for talking
bad about my sister anything was a
trigger and the violence just kept
rising and Rising even in in the group
homes I would fight every single dude in
the group home
um getting into it with all every single
staff he's like I'm just a paycheck I'm
just a paycheck I'm a four thousand
dollar a month kid you know and they
knew how to press my buttons they're
like although you may have fought
everybody in this group home as the you
know the youngest guy
um
the lady told me one day she said I
don't know why you act the way you act I
know why you do the stuff that you do
and she got in my face she said you act
this way because your mama don't want
you she'll never want you who wants a
kid like you you ain't you what are you
and I took that [__] to heart so bad it
just made me go hard I ran in the
streets I started running away
ah and it was it was hard because my mom
lived in in the 40s she lived in the
neighborhood 40s on 46 in Vermont
upstairs I was in a group home and eight
trade gangsters and that automatically
was a conflict you taking me home dude's
looking at me funny I'm coming back
dudes looking at me funny and I'm in
this damn group home so you know we show
up to school I'm going to horse man I
got kicked out of there throwing a damn
chair at the teacher I started smoking
weed just just really running in the
streets I'm getting everybody in the
group home High the youngest dude here
let's you know let's smoke some weed
Squad back you don't want to gang bang
let's go gang bang you know let's let's
really get out here hello
got kicked out of everything to the
point at 12 my mom I came home one day I
threatened her boyfriend
um I put a knife out on them I
threatened her boyfriend and uh because
they she's trying to whip my ass
he was trying to get in between I
thought he was trying to restrain me so
I started fighting him and I'm running
my room and I get my you know I get my
field knife you can buy from anywhere
just have one of the crackheads go get
you one hey go give me a knife all right
little bro I'm gonna buy you a couple
two elevens so you know when he got that
I got my knife now nothing Chuck's under
my bed that was another reason she
kicked me out like you you're carrying
Weapons Under the Bed and you're being
disrespectful and you know Finding
you're 12 years old you ain't here
drinking Hennessy uh
so I came home one night
all my [__] was outside my little bag
that I had it was about Star Wars a Star
Wars overnight bag and you know she left
a note and said you know go back go back
to the foster home you know go go back
to the group home uh I want you over
here so I ran away
and uh before that I confronted the
boyfriend and you know I had the local
dudes of the neighborhood really really
press him and pressure him and get on
his ass you know they fell for me like
that's the little boy that's always
running the streets he always out at
night he ain't never in the house he
just running wild
uh
ran away while leaving school I was
going to Audubon
and I could say
I've never felt more Unity
within you know how do you say the gang
culture
than I felt
being in that that area you know near
the jungles and all that type of stuff
it's it's different over here you know
it was different even the youngsters
they grow up different you know you you
hear them running around you know five
times five times no cut five times like
what the [__] is this you know all of
them know how to fight they all know
karate somehow they all they're all
knowledgeable they all know about black
this black that you know what I'm saying
and I'm stuck in the head like I know
nothing about anything these are kids
that know this [__] they all fighting
they slap boxing they got the freshest
clothes and all that type of stuff and
that's when I got a glimpse of the gang
life like
this means something like they have a
meaning there's something there and that
Audubon on that last day of school I
said you know I'm not not going back
over there to the a trays I'm not going
over here to the 40s I'm gonna just run
away and I was just running away running
through the streets I was at my uncle's
house in the Jays I would sneak out when
he's not there his girlfriend puppet you
know what I'm saying puppet like nah you
you got to go you're making a spot hot
you know we trying to make money over
here you're making a spot hot so
my mom found out where I was at called
the police on me like you know go and
get him out the streets you know he's
here and they pick me up they take me to
77 Division
DCFS has emergency people that they call
to come pick up kids and they took me to
Linwood
and I lived there for about three days
she kicks me out you know my family
member died and I ended up back in
Compton not only did I end up back into
Compton I ended up in a group home
directly behind the house of where my
family's dead stayed at three houses
down from that house behind the dude
that I end up falling up under and being
his little homie was my auntie's house
so I'm like oh I'm home
I'm with my people first day in the
group home I'm out the window
second day in the group home my
established man you know I'm with my
family this is where I'm at y'all can't
tell me nothing curfew is nothing
curfew is nothing so now I'm starting to
take on this institutional mindset of
once I get here I establish dominance if
there's anybody in this house that I
need to have a problem with if we can't
hash it out we gonna fight
you know and it was one of those places
I said they had the big house and Carson
they had the big house they lived over
there in the center views where you know
they had a big house fancy stuff you
know they had three four cars out front
these guys had the Dapper his clothes
and all that you know what I'm saying
it's Carson this is nice you know that
y'all living good you know what was it
Mozelle Pennington's group home yeah the
Pennington Foundation they call it and
um these guys lived good they had
weights everything three four video
games you know when I moved in she just
brought her daughter a brand new car
this old lady even had a money machine
on her bed you go in there she counting
money so [__] you got eight kids four
times eight 32 plus other house has
eight 32 32 is 32 000 from over here 32
000 over here a month
so [__] gold mine I thought about
robbing this old chick
I'm about to Rob this lady so our group
home roaches holes in the wall we got
padlocks on the [__] refrigerators
after six o'clock you can't go in the
fridge
I can't get a juice
you know and then you're taking meds and
it's just crazy it's just
I moved in there with my boy Dwayne and
we just we just hit the streets every
day we hit the streets and we just ran
around smoking drinking partying and now
this this neighborhood I didn't know
what it was years ago this is like the
heart of the east side of Compton Lewis
Park Original East Side Lotus Park which
I came to find out later I was I started
banging the gang and didn't even know
how to spell it it took a dude in a
holding tank one they said me you've
been running around here tagging this
everywhere I'm like yeah remember I
didn't really know how to read like that
so [__] some things I just didn't get
I'm it sounds out and uh
my boy fatal
he's like man this is how you spell the
hood
and um
going back to just in that neighborhood
the essence of it and it wasn't the
fellas that lured me in it was the women
it was these young girls you know it was
my first interaction with with an actual
just person from the hood I've been
around you know Crips and all that type
of stuff but it wasn't an intimate
interaction where you're just talking to
these people and you get to live with
them and you get embraced and it felt it
felt like a natural Embrace when I met
my homegirl lady Damu and it was short
little Creole thing you know curly hair
freckles on her face but was a Savage
this
she's been stabbed by the T Flats you
know I'm saying police nor by her name
hey download what's up blood she keep
walking y'all know who it is and she
already in gang foul you know we we in
stores taking stuff you know she taking
pictures you know here take the head of
homie quinoa in here take pictures so I
can send it to mousy while he locked up
and camping and white and stuff
um
I would just watch her and I watch all
the females able to stay with Fighters
and I said yeah that's when I became
intrigued with this life and
I was walking down the street one day
and and just Belling around and I met my
homie Honcho
and we became best friends
and then I met big honcho then I met
swap meet you know the the locals you
know these these dudes is like Legends
like walking talking Legends and it's
like damn y'all embrace me y'all didn't
even judge me y'all not looking at this
group home van that y'all see me pulling
up in y'all don't care about the
padlocks on the refrigerators y'all like
man come on over here and they would
feed me you know and a grandmother may
may she rest in peace you know
she would bring me in and she would give
me assignments to make me feel
worthwhile like I was part of a family
she was giving me money say go down here
to Eddie's liquor store and tell them I
need this this baby and I'll be like all
right you know I felt a sense of Pride
about that
or she would say go pick up the kids and
walk them from around the corner from
from uh from uh the school go over there
go over there to Whaley go to Roosevelt
now at this time in in the city of
Compton it was this was racial it's been
racial but it's heavy racial you know
Lucas parking at Seven O's never got
along loose parking and T Flats can
never get along we'll never get along as
long as you hitting a [__] killer on
the wall these are known facts so I
would have to go and get the kids me
young man get the kids walk them me and
little honcho me and my best friend we
were walking and we'd take the kids all
the way home now we got a duck everybody
we got a duck the mobs we got to duck
the seven holes we got a duck whoever's
across company build a bar that that's
that's coming over here and um we got a
duck this one particular individual who
was you know he was riding around in the
van and he was gunning at kids
he was a gun in their kids he was like
damn like this dude chased us we chase
them right come on we gotta go he's
chasing kids around
like what is this you know
later on I will identify that as
guerrilla warfare you know I'm saying
these are tactics that these duels are
taking out here in these streets to get
their kids I don't want the next next
lineage of these these dudes to rise up
so let me nip this in the bud before it
becomes more of a problem for me and
that's what I've seen later I understand
it then
and um
when people speak about just just the
the gang life and different cultures
been I can't really speak for other
neighborhoods or you know people that
grew up and it was
men from Lotus Park taught me just
Geographics going in Dominguez High if
you cross on this side of the bridge of
Compton Boulevard you know what I'm
saying
you a [__] that's where you no matter
what
if you cross this side of the bridge
okay
all that is Bloods all that is Piru so
if I get caught slipping coming out the
wrong gate that's my ass you know what
I'm saying if I do this and they're not
asking as long as they see you walking
with this crowd over there all right
we're just gonna identify you as that
you know that's that's all it is let me
ask you where you from as long as you
stay over there and you associate with
them people then you know that's all we
need and um
begin getting into the gang life
I was never asked hey come get put on
Lotus Park they was trying to force me
away man go to school man go do this go
do that
I was out late at night it was my homie
skipped I went and picked me up for
Lotus park at 10 o'clock at night
because I'm just standing outside
running around and you know he he drove
me home get up out these streets he
bought me my first pair of football
cleats he's home you know you don't have
to be a gang member to have money you
don't have to be a gang member to be a
you know a gangster or be seen as this
but I seen them
I want it to be like that
I wanted to be that that big dude you
know I'm saying I want to be that dude
with the tattoos that swole everybody
respects everybody loves them everybody
wants to be like them
you know these dudes can cross the
tracks and go to other dudes
neighborhoods and they respect them I
was like damn that's that's what I want
to be like that's my black superhero
you know they walk like me talk like me
breathe like me all that I want to
replicate that and um
one day you know a dude named too Swift
you know that's where I get my name from
a dude named too Swift one of the most
hardest rappers that that underground
accomping that you've ever hear and um
he always had me around his family he
always he always taught me things he
always took me under under his Lane you
know even even when I was out doing
stupid [__] like running around at night
with guns he'll come find me in the
streets man give me this damn gun
you know Dan when I got to the point
where I was actually holding guns hey
man come here man what you got going on
oh man I walked up to you know my
brother one day I call him my bro and I
I showed him a nine he's got a brand new
P89 Ruger loaded in order I don't even
know how to pop the bullets out put them
back in I know the [__] it or nothing
all I knew was like look turn the safety
off put on some black gloves and if [__]
gets sketchy point and shoot
didn't even know how to do any of the
other stuff you know
he looked at me he seen it it's like all
right I'm gonna show you bam he showed
me he did this
showed the gun then he looked at me
clean out the shelves you know cleaned
everything before he before he gave it
back you took the clip
said nah I'm gonna take this clip from
you because
you gonna do something crazy out here
even when you know when it was wartime
and I was outside with the other guns it
was
it was it was always the individuals
that was like get out the streets
go to school even you know these dudes
mother they mother you know all these
dudes his brothers not I had swab meat
honcho Swift little loc all of my
brothers and their mama would show up to
school
and be tripping on me like you know my
mama why are you showing up the school
tripping on me about not being in class
because she just wanted me to do better
she actually cared that was the
comparison of being in a group home and
being and and just out there in society
you know their their mom she tried to
take me in and even adopt me at one
point and uh of course all the [__] that
you got to go through with DCFS they
they denied it so I was like you know
I'm just I'm Street Pound so 12 years
old I'm walking up and down Compton
Boulevard patrolling no shirt on red hat
to the back you know not even red
burgundy burgundy to the back you know
my homies P-Funk P-Funk alfonka no Funk
at all it's it's power you know I'm up
and down to build up I'm sniffing
cocaine at 12 smoking sure pack some New
Ports you know what I'm saying I got my
packs in my sock
you know I got my gun on me if I ain't
got my nine I got my deuce deuce in my
boot and I'm out here patrolling I'm
willing to die if it is this is it is
what it is
you know what I'm saying from San Luis
all the way around to the boulevard all
the way these all this territory I'm
running around I'm tagging I'm hitting
up everything
and I was like this is it for me I'm
I'll die for this this is what it's
about
I'm loved here
this my family
even though the people that you would
think are the the Thugs and you know the
gangsters they was like nah man get out
the streets even my first love who was
their little sister my first love D
Dante get off the streets the streets is
doing something to you but it's
it took a toll on me I was what you know
as much love as I'm getting from these
dudes in the hood it's still not feeling
that void of losing my father and my
stepfather my grandma my other Grandma
my auntie not having my mom there for me
not having a family there for me all the
support that I felt that I need so it
just went more add the drugs add the
feeling of power that I have with this
pistol in my hand
I got a pistol this is it's gonna answer
all the questions we're gonna get to the
point you know what what you gonna do
and I start doing [__] in the streets
um whenever I couldn't find a gun I just
picked up a knife
you know
I realized where I got that [__] from I
got that from from seeing my stepdad
stabbed my cousin for playing with him
so I get the turn from before I even
went to prison you don't play with grown
folks they'll cut you he was playing too
much so he had to get that respect
restore let me stuck him in his arm made
him bleed yeah you see blood now you
understand those are the mindsets and um
I began to just start doing a bunch of
robberies I said all right I'm not in
the group home and Foster homes anymore
um whenever it was too late and I
couldn't get inside Swift house or I
couldn't go down there to the dead end
to the blocks or the homies house or
keep my house I would just be running
around just in the middle of the night
doing robberies
uh I would Rob people on the streets you
know it just triggered triggered you
know this sense of power I got money and
I'm a kid I'm 13 14. you know like all
right money I got I got this much amount
of money I didn't care about the money
see when you don't earn [__] you don't
respect it so I was taking but it was
just it's just an adrenaline rush so
just Robbie Robbie Robin probably
everything on the damn east side when I
was high off cocaine I probably went
around and did it just running around
just all right I'm about to take this
I'd rather DVD man the corn man this
person that person one night I'm out
there with playing a knockout game
so I can get some beer from from Pisa
dude just just running around to being a
real Tyrant just doing crazy [__] I'm
going all the way over here to the Kelly
Parks I'm in in other dudes
neighborhoods I'm not supposed to be in
them over here in the South Side Crips
over there I got a gun on me you can't
tell me nothing you know even though you
know just a grown man game he dudes I
play for keeps you just you're doing
this
and uh time caught up with me just that
fast you know robberies fighting
uh stealing dudes guns out their front
yard jumping in people backyards beating
up people just just going over here
doing [__] even you know I got Drew Down
On One Night in the different lanes and
you know they saved my life you know
just being just impulsive as hell
and um it caught up with me and I ended
up going I ended up going through the uh
the ringer
got caught two months after turning 13.
DCFS said you know go ahead and take
them so I was turned over to uh the
probation department Los Angeles County
went through that whole trial just of
everything that you can describe you
know everything just imagine kids kids
after kids after kids in cages they
can't even get out to use the bathroom
there's no toilets in these cells so
they're pissing in Corners [__] in
Corners some of them got hepatitis it's
blood spit on the wall they're pissing
out of Windows dudes are hanging
themselves you know you you see these
things then I was kicked out of juvenile
hall and sent to Y.A why a
California Youth Authority
did more damage to more kids
more trauma to more kids and I would say
anything that prison can compare to
on some of you you want to see
teenagers seven eight at a time gang
bang raping a god
selling to God
you know what I'm saying selling this
dude just got sold because oh boy this
kid big as hell whoa knockout artists
you know what I'm saying this dude
hesitated for four seconds to show his
impulse rate because that's all why he
is they teach you impulse jump at it
every chance you get you jump you go you
fight you don't show any after four
seconds you don't do something to
anybody they drop you as a lame you're a
Levi they tell you go find a daddy
you under somebody's arms you're
somebody's [__] essentially and you got
to go through that you get off the bus
they send you a list I'm from Pyro I get
to Preston California Youth Authority I
get off the bus they send me a list you
got to fight all these dudes and you
better do it in 72 hours then the game
coordinators come they bring me out look
we'll tell you this you could say you're
from Lotus Park but you can't say you're
from Piru here PA rules Don't Walk the
Line
oh you know we we want to do this you
trying to test my gangster man I'm
walking the line
went out there had a few fights with
with some dudes I sliced open nose
fracture you know jaw swollen
police don't know anything
because they got one of theirs in there
you know they got the biggest [__] I
ever seen at that age working there in
the weight room getting up this is a
staff
he gets off the bench big old blunt
killer on his back
blood killer and all the Crips are
surrounding them
I walk in there I'll fight him him him
we do our thing all right
you know I didn't realize that up north
we got beef I didn't realize that they
had all these alliances so it was just
continuous fighting and the cops
couldn't figure out how this dude was
fighting and I end up in Paso Robles
uh close that facility I closed yts
which is known as Gladiator school where
they they had kids back there in back
rooms tied up on five-point spreads
locked behind locked behind just door
after door you couldn't even hear
anything
in cages like these these were dudes in
cages and the cops hated us because we
were tried as adults can't wait for you
dudes to go to prison we hate you
[__] y'all killed that later
y'all killed that lady you know
everybody knows the story about the lady
that was killed in Youth Authority where
they had a barbecue and the kid took her
killed her and threw her in a dumpster
and locked in the dumpster went back in
and went to sleep
ever since that happened since the 90s
oh they hate every single person try as
an adult
so for my 18th birthday CDC granted me a
gift and they transferred me over to
Chino and I was to stay there in my
drone Hall where you know they got
roaches flying in the room there's no
windows everything is busted out and I
was waiting to go to Pelican Bay just
turned 18 waiting to go to Pelican Bay
and um
yeah
fortunately I didn't end up there
they dumped me off in a well stopped at
Tehachapi oh you don't have no place for
you here and they sent me to a new
Delano you know the super prison
that's why I started my prison census of
17 years two strikes and that's where I
learned
my identity as a black man my entire
life I didn't know what the [__] a black
man was like he couldn't tell me what a
black man school only said that we were
slaves you know they always said you
wanna you wanna keep something from a
[__] you hide it in a book
and I got in there with my my OG named
skimp out of Pacoima a little short dude
did all my tattoos on me but he gave me
a sense of understanding of who a black
man was and he had been in jail he had
been through Y.A and he would put me on
a hot seat every day every time I [__]
up
and he'll have me draw and even when I
tried to fight him was I tried to attack
him one day and I jumped on him with a
razor and he had hit me with the tattoo
gun just ran me real fast he's like oh
yeah make you melt like butter don't it
you know and I I seen it and he said
well you want to fight let's fight give
me what you got
level four this dude has been in [__]
Pelican Bay for 14 years and I tried to
fight him and he toyed with me so much
little dude and I thought because I was
bigger I could get him he toyed with me
he tied me up
like a hawk Hawk tired of me uh wrists
to ankles he set me on the floor and um
he set me on the floor he put all the
blankets on me did all that type of
stuff and he left me there and he put
his feet on top of me and he drunk ice
he said when you're ready to talk
I'll entire you matter of fact you untie
yourself because you'll figure it out
and I panicked I got mad he's like yeah
get it out get it out and I got it and I
I stopped I took a deep breath and I
said show me how to do it and he show me
here do this do this do this breathe
then he showed me how to work out it was
the man in prison that that taught me
how to shave taught me how to do my hair
taught me how to read a lot of things
identify with what a black man was how
to respect other races and in cars and
entities and all that and you know it's
these men that I see that'll never get
out
they did they're never going to some of
them have become content they've put in
so much work over the years they need
all these new laws that everybody oh we
pass these new laws and all that type of
[__] they're just buried under the
paperwork sitting at the damn bottom
dudes got seven in life been sitting in
jail for 30 years all his family's dead
you know what I'm saying this whole
[__] family is dead what does he have
to go home to
nothing
so he's like I'd rather stay in here
with them
right now if you ask me would you rather
go sit down with the president and eat a
meal and and pick his brain or would you
rather go back in or sit in a chow hall
with these men
which would you choose going back in
there with the fellas
you'll never understand me you'll never
walk in my shoes
I'll provide some type of Hope for them
because that's all they ask when you get
out go out there and live your best life
we don't want nothing
I went through uh
hella [__] in there I went through
so much during that during that time
let's see uh
conspiracy that attempted murder on the
police
end up fighting that
um
at my last last three years in prison
well let's
let's go to how I met my brother this is
the funniest thing let's go to how I met
my brother my brother Brian James
we ran across each other we we're on the
shoe kick out yard and old Corcoran
um you know old Corgan has a reputation
of being you know you a big dog you're
going to be there Pelican Bale Cork and
calipat you're a big dog you're gonna be
there and it's a shoe kickout yard and
uh they just had lifted the theme and
let out all the guys that were
indeterminate and they're all in the
yard
um
we were in a recycling crew and we're
picking up a bunch of [__] trash and I
noticed this dude and I'm like What's Up
lonely that was his name and we chilled
we talked
but we went on about our business
because we still got to respect these
these boundaries of different cars and
different races and I didn't really meet
this man and sit down and talk to him
until we got into this this dog program
they brought me out of the shoe a lady
named Bonita Weaver the captain their
sister brought me out of this shoe she
said I know you didn't try to you
weren't going to do anything to the
staff so I'm going to bring you out of
the shoe won't you be in this dog
program
and I had a choice to make I could have
went back over here with my big homie
who had the whole entire yard sold up
everything you wanted he got it you know
what I'm saying he's that guy and he
said you want to do the dog program
little bro I said yeah I'm gonna do the
dog program I'm gonna go over here I
don't believe it's gonna come but I'm
gonna go he said you want to leave all
this follow read this that he he popping
he like here you want to leave this for
that
and I told him you know
I didn't choose to be your homie and
move in here with you for everything
that you got I did it because you're my
homeboy and I learned so much [__] from
you know I'm saying you blessed me when
I came here
you know let me go over here and learn
this and make this working and I did uh
the Marley's Mutts dog program
when I met this I met this this
astounding brother you know man running
around running around just who is this
white dude who's an essay
you know
what the [__] is this dude right here
rapping all this goddamn Tupac and all
this [__] you know what I'm saying at
the time you know he was cholo down so
my boy got the he got the pants up to
the navel you know who the [__] is this
dude and I met so many characters
in this program that I never met before
because it allowed us to lead the
politics to the side
you know it the staff left it along they
let us do that but it was the
individuals that seen it for what it was
that had been in prison for so long and
was like let these people have this this
Joy
the Mexican Mafia here you know
the the areas no we're gonna leave that
alone the bgs now we get on the Bloods
the Crips everything you can think of
they're all like that's that let these
men be who they are without the imminent
threat of something happening for doing
something wrong because all you want to
do in prison is be Flawless you don't
want to have none of that [__] on you
don't want to have nothing on your
record to say I'll use a buster user use
a chump or you sold out or you're a dope
head and all that so we were able to
live and coexist
in unison and you've seen men grow
so you pay all these people this amount
of money to do this that is the other
and all this type of [__] all these
psychologists that can't solve anything
or none of these type of things and in
the midst of this it was a war going on
they were just dropping protective
custody dudes off on the yard and the
cops will do this hey here's his
paperwork
he's a snitch he did this he did that
and they have his pace and they have
plastered at r r so all the inmates you
know they're walking around you know
it's Predators the Sharks is out and
they would see this [__] oh now we got
to get this dude
so all the stuff that I was just I was
just observing like damn you know this
is this is the real Willie Lynch that
are going on right here
they building their infrastructure
they're keeping the money going because
the more violence that you have
the more money we're gonna have so let's
bring these protective custody dudes
over here who [__] up over here on
this yard let's drop them back off on
the general population yard and let them
have their way and it happened and in
the midst of this
you had dogs creating peace
dogs a dog that was going to be put down
a dog that was on death row that walked
in the same [__] cage that we walked
in back there in a shoe had that same
pace and back and forth you know they
asked why you want to be a dog trainer
because I understand them they
understand me
you know we don't need to talk we just
got that Vibe we got that energy we got
that instinct
you know some people have intellect we
got Instinct dudes in prison have
Instinct we will we feel it before we go
outside something's gonna happen
you know we we hear that we hear that
meaning 14 [__] in the morning it's a
cold feeling to know that
you know I moved the wrong way I crossed
that line you're gonna hit me with that
same thing that goes in the AK from
close range
and um
me and Brian met I've seen the struggles
that he had you know some of his his
family members have passed
I seen that he really wanted to get to
that that level three Brian James will
not be out of prison if he had not
sacrificed what he sacrificed
did those programs to get to that level
three he was still being Corcoran right
now he would still be there because I
went through it
and we we graduated he left I had to
depart I had to leave my brother the dog
program got snatched away from us so
dudes were running around we were
hurting
we took our babies you know you had
dudes coming out and seeing dogs in 30
years you know that's how I met the
leader of the ABS there walked up to
this door let me see a dog man what the
[__] you got a swastik on your head
[__] you why would I talk to you and he
told me you know I thought I would die
before I seen the dog again so I gave
him a dog and I went over and see grown
men just bleed with happiness boys again
you take them back and give them that
moment of peace you know and um after
the dogs left you know we were
devastated
I spiraled back into the negativity I
got one full fledge you know they took
all the dog took all the dogs off the
yard took the big dog my big homie he
gone this [__] is crazy you know I mean
he told me you know I'm lacing you you
know who's gonna be there for the homies
these the homies who's gonna be here for
the homies I'm close to the house
I get caught up
craziest moment ever
I got hit with a staff assault where
Officer says that I broke his leg in
seven different places headbutted him
and punched them while in cuffs Shackled
and all that after I just left the ICU
from you know damn near dying six days
in there [__] on myself throwing up
stuff IVs everywhere no liquid any
poisoning myself from a botch surgery
that had in the prison and um I got
[__] up the staff they they put me
back there and I had to struggle for
that last three years I went to the shoe
covert hit
I would rather watch a man fight for
their life with a knife in their hand
than watch the way these dudes suffered
coughing hacking up blood and it ain't
like they gave you medical attention nah
they took us when we got sick they drug
us out ourselves they took all our
property and put us in a [__]
jumpsuit if they didn't give you a
jumpsuit they put you in your boxers and
some house shoes they walked into the
shoe where it's perforated doors the
same shoe where they had to pay for play
in the 90s where they had to fight to
the death
just that bad energy that aura that was
over this [__] and they left the
center to die
families don't know what you got going
on and the inmates didn't give the other
inmates we didn't give each other now
y'all brought that in you brought your
sick ass into work to make extra money
and you've got all of us sick and you
watch these dudes die dudes didn't even
understand when they were gonna go home
they had release dates I was close to
the house I had four lawyers fighting a
case over this Officer Down in Kings
County this weird racist ass [__] they
had going on down there where they told
my lawyers were four law professors they
said this is Kings County we get our we
get our bread and butter out those
inmates it's like shooting fish in a
bucket I don't care we know he we know
he didn't do it
we know he didn't do it but we wanted
conviction that's all that matters we
want a conviction
I'll take a polygraph test any day of
the week to prove my innocence but they
wouldn't let me do it why because they
want a conviction
and I went through the case
and another blow hit me
you know another blow hit me to where as
I
I had to resort to violence while
getting ready to go to a halfway house
when one of my older homies big ones you
know he's a big dog but that [__]
liquor that liquor that liquor do
something to you bring out aside
and he disrespected me to the point of
someone he called me a [__] he called
me a [__] he said you know I can get you
hit in any prison and yada he went all
the way down the line and all these are
violation violations on what they call
you a [__] in prison so nobody call you
about this name don't nobody test your
sexuality don't nobody tell you you're
gonna get touched that's a threat
so I held it in I held it in and I was
like but I gotta do something
I gotta do I gotta do it because after
this the Predator is going to come out
you let that slide now they're gonna
come and eat no matter what they're so
level four they're gonna come and eat
I want to go home but I still got to
live here this ain't over to the last
seconds and I went in there and
I caught him slipping
and I punched him two pieces he went
down
and one of his comrades tried to come
get in and one of my homies got on him
and he tried to get up and I'm telling
man watch out you know it's over I just
I just had to get that out of my system
he wanted to fight some more and I'm
like man this I hit him again he real
decent but I gotta he mobilize this dude
you know while doing this I'm thinking
like I gotta get immobilizing so I
grabbed him and I put him in a rear
naked Chokehold like real UFC in the
middle of all this everybody's going off
there shooting a non-lethal round mini
14 and I got him and I'm choking him and
he goes to sleep in my arms and I'm
whispering to him what do you run who do
you run
you don't run [__] you gonna make me
[__] up my life you don't want me to go
home I thought your wisdom saying it to
him I thought I was whistling but I was
yelling
and the homie that was over here
fighting this dude he's like no
he said don't let him go let him go he's
finished shoot he got the mini he's
finished shoot let him go and he pulled
me off of him and they were like you
know they sprayed him down
had already shot the other dude in the
hand broke his hand bone came out from
the mini uh from the non-lethal 44 and I
let him go and he rolled over on his
face and it was lifeless
I'm gonna go home and I gotta do this to
my folks
I thought we was homies why would you do
this to me
why would you force me to exert this
and
he was there and he was sleeping my life
flashed before myself and I'm never
getting out of jail this dude ain't
moving I'm never getting out this is
over this is over
you know and I was like they won and at
that moment he inhaled and she started
snoring and blood just started coming
out everywhere
they kicked me off that yard
actually it kicked me off that yard
after there was a riot
I was no longer allowed to go there I
had confidential just kites drop I ended
up in Folsom
with with a young brother in a Cell we
left from Corcoran you know and this
this is touchy for me so I'm I'm gonna
go through this one and this brother
they put us at odds he's from Sacramento
and I'm from Compton and you know we
both we both may have been you know
blood power and all that but there's
always a conflict and it was always just
we never sat down we would always talk
he would talk over here for his guys I
would talk for my guys you know it was
always you know don't speak on bompton
but we ain't gonna speak on sack you
know y'all y'all stay like that but the
whole time we were saying the same
[__] thing all we want is unity and
peace
that's all we we trying to go home and
they put us on the bus and we ended up
in new Folsom again we were in sale
together
and I got to know this man like you know
I got to know him I got to know this
dude it's my bro
and I stayed there and Folsom said you
know we're gonna kick you out you don't
deserve it
cork is always sending us you guys up
here you know you you're not supposed to
be in this prison you're supposed to be
in another prison they bump you up a
level higher and I was in there with
this dude named baby drugs and this this
my guy from Sacramento
and he said we got to get out we got to
make it right in these streets we gotta
we gotta do right for these kids
we got to make it right we got to get
out here we got to fix our hand we did a
lot of [__] up
you know he used to tell me about his
son you know and he said tell me how he
wanted to you know I want to go give my
life up to Allah but I'm not quite sure
and we all sit there we would read man
we made plans we sat down did the
business plan to format how to do this
how to get the LLC how to do all that
clothing line rap and music you know all
that type of stuff he got out before me
living lavish living his best life
United with his son taking care of his
mama real pillar in the hood you know
and this goes to show why why
you know we lose that time and we don't
get it back and we got to cherish the
ones we've got let the people know let
them know you love them
you know what I'm saying let them know
you love them
if I die today would you remember me
tomorrow
that's the [__] you gotta ask people
and that man ended up getting out
I end up getting up in a halfway house
we stand in touch he plugged me in with
so many people community activists and
all that type of stuff
and you know a couple months ago I get a
call they say you know drugs got killed
ain't even been out here
and I'm broke down I was in a dog park I
had all these dogs around me
and I broke down and I told Brian I said
bro they they killed Baby D
you know they they walked up on this man
when he was in the sun in the car with
his son and he killed this man in front
of his kids
not anything I think gangster
that ain't the cold that we that we are
that we're supposed to be up under they
don't do that [__] that's savagery
and I said man I want to get back into
the streets
I was like man I want it I want to talk
to his son I don't know what to tell his
[__] son
do I say hey bro make it happen go ahead
and get it back in blood
or do I tell them what his dad would
want
and I stay this course and Status path
and I talked to this man and I the 16
year old boy just lost his dad just lost
his dad two weeks and I spoke to him and
I said you know
what do you want from the world
I said I want for the kids to be safe
I want to know how they father
and I want to heal
now if this kid can go through this if
Brian James can go through this if all
these these people around here went
going through the stuff they're going
through if my mama went through what she
went through my sister went through what
she went through all these wonderful
people that have stories hard in their
minds if they're able to go through it
is up here and make an excuse of why I
can't be the best image for somebody
so that's why I go in and I the same
program that liberated me you know the
same people that came to visit me they
gave me a job to go in and teach kids
you know
and I'm able to to talk to these kids
like you know nobody else can talk to
him because you ain't live the life that
they that they lived you know I'm saying
you you can't feel the way that they
feel they know when it's nursing there's
no passion and nowhere and there's no
love they know when they're just a
paycheck you know
[__] this is you want to sum it all up
so we ain't even got to keep going forth
with this I'm I'm what you call the
product of the system
I'm the modern day slave who's been
freed and put back into a world where
it's completely strange and different
you know look back how they did the
slaves back then you know you're free go
ahead but you never gave them education
knowledge understanding you never gave
them a platform to say go ahead and live
your best life and let me this you know
hit this you nah it's here you butt
naked in these streets sink or swim
pressure bus pipes do what you do
and you know this is where I'm at with
it just I gotta do the best that I can I
got to keep on going I gotta get
somebody watching I've affected so many
people in such a Negative manner you
know I'm saying that now I ain't got no
choice but to do right
is at the end of the day when I meet my
maker
ain't no raft like that
and that's as simple as it is
great talking doctor thank you